now I've got certain breaking news to
bring you this from Devon and Cornwall
police it's about an incident at a
school you might recall in Devon uh
yesterday we were being told that a 16
year old boy has been charged with two
counts of attempted murder and one
account of gbh with intent over a
violent assault on two teenage boys and
an adult at this school you can see the
sign there and you can see uh tapes off
area this is a Blundell School in
Tiverton it's a private school in Devon
police we know were called at around one
in the morning in the early hours of
yesterday to a building on the site of
the school following reports of a
serious assault the 16 year old boy from
Tiverton was arrested on suspicion of
three counts of causing Grievous bodily
harm within 10 well that 16 year old boy
has now been charged with two counts of
attempted murder and one account of gbh
with intent one of the boys we
understand is is it a critical condition
in hospital the second is seriously
injured in a stable condition that was
according to a police statement last
night a third person who was injured in
the incident a member of staff was
discharged from hospital yesterday so uh
two teenage boys at an adult
injured at Blundell School in tibetan in
the early hours of Friday morning a 16
year old boy has now been charged with
two counts of attempted murder and one
count of gbh with intent according to
Devon and Cornwall police